lightning doesn't strike twice in the
same way
common weather myth lightning doesn't
strike twice it does absolutely all the
time
now the odds of any point on earth
getting struck twice are slim because
you know lightning is the size of a
pencil
but think of the empire state building
or some other skyscraper that has a
lightning rod on it
lightning strikes there all the time so
lightning can strike twice hey gq
i'm david yeomans and this is the
breakdown
first up the day after tomorrow we have
live coverage now from our fox 11
chopper
are you there bart uh yes i'm here
natural disasters
are naturally occurring horrible
catastrophes that we have
no control over and that we often times
can't even predict
some natural disasters like tornadoes or
hurricanes they happen
at different parts of the world and they
can happen many times in a given year
right off the bat this is a really
spectacular scene but this part of the
movie is taking place in la
while la has had some small weak
tornadoes over the past 50 or 60 years
we've never had multiple tornadoes like
this in los angeles and we've never had
intense tornadoes like these appear to
be in los angeles so a tornado is a
violently
spinning and rising column of air
typically it happens in a supercell
thunderstorm which is when
you have a really intense thunderstorm
with all this rising air called an
updraft
but then you also have what's called
wind shear which is winds
at different heights in the atmosphere
blowing different directions
and also at different speeds and if all
those things come together just right
you have not only rising air inside of
the storm but you have rising and
spinning
air inside of the storm these tornadoes
here have more of the appearance of
what's called a supercell thunderstorm
so these are the tornadoes that happen
in oklahoma
or the midwest or even parts of texas
this is where the the conditions in the
atmosphere are conducive for
really intense and spectacular tornadoes
the ones that happen in la
on the rare occasion that they do happen
they would generally be
much skinnier much smaller to make a
tornado like this
in the midwest where it usually happens
you need warm moist air down at ground
level down at the surface
generally in la you have this cool
stable air near the surface
and actually the air a few thousand feet
high is warmer than it is down at the
ground so it makes tornadoes like this
very unlikely
we have live coverage now from our fox
11 chopper
are you there bart well we have observed
multiple tornadoes at once
it's usually just two tornadoes side by
side and that even in the midwest or
tornado alley
is very rare so seeing something like
this in los angeles where they
really rarely even get tornadoes would
be pretty unheard of
the most tornadoes i'm aware of
happening simultaneously is is three
but that is it was from an old
photograph and it's quite rare
tornadoes are so sensitive to their
environment
and that's why they never last for that
long usually at least they need
everything to
be just right and if one thing disrupts
that it's gone
you know you would think it'd be very
dangerous to fly a helicopter near a
tornado but they actually do this pretty
frequently
in places like oklahoma a lot of the
news stations up there have helicopters
and during tornado outbreaks
they'll put their choppers up in the sky
to give their viewers the best view
of the tornado so this can actually be
done
that's kind of a common myth actually is
that mountains protect you from
tornadoes or hills protect you from
tornadoes the truth is that tornadoes
can't happen in mountains
and they can happen in hilly terrain why
we typically think of tornadoes as
happening on flat land
that's just because of where tornado
alley is it's in the midwest in kansas
oklahoma and missouri
and most of that land is flat but it's
not the flat land that causes the
tornadoes
it's just happens to be where the
meteorological ingredients come together
the us has the most tornadoes out of
anywhere in the world and we'll get
hundreds of tornadoes every single year
maybe even some that we don't know about
because they happen where the radar
can't see very well or where
nobody actually saw it with their eyes
what you're seeing are two actual
tornadoes striking los
angeles international airport wait wait
it looks like they joined and formed one
large tornado oh my god
this is unrealistic just from the news
perspective because when you're a
reporter
live on air you would never be driving
and having your photographer in the
front seat
driving is distracting enough driving in
a tornado is really distracting
two tornadoes like this typically don't
combine into one it's not completely
unheard of their circulations don't
necessarily attract each other
if anything they kind of like to be
separated so when two tornadoes come
together they may actually fizzle out
entirely because they may kind of
counteract one another or mess up the
other's environment
unbelievable i've never seen it okay
wait
pause it there's so much stuff to tear
apart so that was a seismograph which
measures earthquakes
so apparently now there's tornadoes
causing earthquakes which is not a thing
earthquakes are a geological phenomenon
that happens underground
and tornadoes are an atmospheric thing
they happen up above the ground
if a tornado throws some debris you know
that's been lofted up in the cloud and
then it kind of drops it outside of the
wind zone if you will that's realistic
that can happen something can plop down
onto the ground
but if this billboard is getting carried
straight up
sideways and it creams this guy and
takes his body away just like that
he wouldn't have been able to be
standing there in the first place
because i know from experience in
hurricanes it's almost impossible
for a grown person to stand up in a 60
65 mile an hour wind
or stronger these violent tornadoes have
winds of well over 100 or 150 miles an
hour it looks like so if they're going
to throw this billboard
past him it is unrealistic that he would
just be able to stand there
until the billboard crushes him
that destruction of a well-built
skyscraper is
very difficult for any tornado to
accomplish even an ef5's the strongest
on the scale the enhanced fujita scale
zero is the weakest on the tornado scale
they have winds of less than 100 miles
per hour
ef5 is the strongest and those have
winds of
over 200 miles per hour we've even had
doppler radar measurements of tornadic
winds over 300 miles per hour before
which is pretty unheard of all right
let's fast forward to later in this same
movie
so right there we were looking from
space down into a really intense
hurricane probably a category four or
five
and the scale only goes up to five this
is unrealistic because a hurricane is a
really warm cored
storm you would never have a hurricane
in a snowstorm or whatever's going on
here
simultaneously in the same place
hurricanes have really moist
warm air feeding into them kind of like
a tornado you can't have a
cold cord hurricane like this one
appears to be
i love what this thing is modeled after
because it is modeled after a real
historical event ten thousand years ago
a mini ice age
it was called the younger driest event
so what happened was
the earth was warming 10 000 years ago
and that global warming actually melted
so much of the ice from greenland
into the north atlantic ocean that that
fresh water melt
threw off all of the ocean currents
europe especially went into a mini ice
age on a very very short scale just
about 10 years
that in the scale of climate was called
abrupt climate change but
happening like this is very unrealistic
where in this movie it just happens in
in minutes or hours
to get something like this this looks
like you're pouring liquid nitrogen
all over it which is like 400 degrees
below zero fahrenheit skyscrapers can
survive
negative 20 or negative 40 degrees as
long as they're built for it like we
have up in the northern us and in canada
actually having something freeze the
building like this and explode the
windows
that's very unrealistic as far as being
caused from weather if there were some
sudden freeze like this
the air wouldn't travel downward if
anything in the atmosphere actually when
you have sinking air
it heats the air up so having the air
crawl down the buildings like this
into this ultra freeze is a little shaky
so a second ago we were kind of in the
eye of the hurricane you could see they
call that the stadium effect where
you're looking at this
stadium it's like football stadium and
you're the player of clouds around you
that are 40 or 50 000 feet high
and that's real for a hurricane but it's
not real for whatever intense freeze
this is the eye of the hurricane like
that you would see the sun and you would
see the spectacular ring of clouds
around you
but it wouldn't be below zero like it is
here it'd be really warm actually
don't let the fire go out this whole
monster
you know coming through the hallways at
you is is not quite how weather works
in a fire like that could keep the room
warm if it's below zero
in the rest of the house or in the rest
of that building but then of course the
question becomes how long does it stay
that cold outside from this disaster
and how long can you keep the fire going
so in freezing temperatures it's always
good to stay at home
because a lot of people get in trouble
traveling on the roadways in a snowstorm
and then they end up sliding off the
road or getting into a car accident and
then they're stranded so if you do have
to travel
we always recommend that you have a
survival kit basically in the trunk
blankets big parkas or jackets some food
or water the best way to do it though is
to just stay home
i really like what the movie is modeled
after global warming actually leading to
abrupt global cooling because that did
happen 10 000 years ago
but happening in this way and this
dramatic with the whole hurricane
spinning over you
those were all added in by hollywood
unfortunately
next up the crown
london has been brought to a halt by
dense fog which has descended overnight
good god the meteorological office has
issued a statement saying that the
persistent anti-cyclone
over london is to blame this is very
meteorologically accurate
so this was the great london smog of
1952 and
thousands of people died and they said
it's because of an anti-cyclone well
cyclone is a storm and typically storms
have
rising air and that's how clouds and
rain form
in an anti-cyclone it's kind of like the
opposite air actually
sinks on top of you so if you have air
sinking on top of you and you're in
1950s london with
no pollution controls it smushes all
that smog which would usually disperse
into the higher levels of the atmosphere
right down at ground level it's sort of
like a temperature inversion that you
see over la
and it can really create super dense and
very very unhealthy smog and that's what
happened
for a few days smog is like a dirty fog
smog is caused by pollution it's
particles like soot or ash or
car exhaust that hang out at ground
level
fog is just a cloud on the ground
so a fog is much more pure to last for
some time
be careful out there it's a real pea
super
this lasted so long because of the
weather pattern dirty growing populous
city
was emitting all this stuff into the
atmosphere and usually they can do that
because the wind blows it away or
it disperses into the levels of the
atmosphere but this persistent
sinking air and very calm conditions in
the city
just trapped all the emissions and all
the pollutants right there
and it was actually so unhealthy that it
killed thousands of people in a short
amount of time
in some cities around the world you know
los angeles parts of china
where we have a lot of people in a tiny
area
and certain weather patterns you can get
smog and really dangerous hazardous air
that's bad to breathe you see people
wearing masks just walking around even
before covet 19. la has such bad smog
for instance because
the cold pacific ocean makes the air
right here at the surface
and in la cooler than it would otherwise
be if you have cold air under warm air
it's just trapped right there in place
and that's why some of the smog can get
trapped too
so this is actually a bad idea in
pollution and smog that's that thick and
that unhealthy
you don't want to be outside and
especially outside exerting yourself
where you breathe more of the particles
in
you want to be inside because inside
even in 1950s london
it would have provided you some level of
protection from that outside dirty air
and now you know with our air filtration
in our homes and businesses it would
provide you a lot of protection from air
that dirty she
wanted to keep her appointment which is
admirable but it's actually what killed
a lot of people is
being out in it for a long time next up
only the brave
prepare deployment side right here now
can't go back up there
there's no time jesse this is about a
real fire in arizona
that uh killed a bunch of expert
firefighters lightning is actually a
huge cause
of wildfires and it was the cause of
this actual fire in reality as well
it's especially dangerous in the desert
where you can have what's called dry
lightning
it's a thunderstorm that's producing
lightning and thunder
and it's trying to produce rain but the
rain actually evaporates on its way down
to the ground because the air is so dry
in a desert
so then you have a spark right but you
don't have any water falling from the
storm to
put a fire out so lightning caused fires
are actually super frequent and they're
very very dangerous
huge fires can actually create their own
weather systems it's fascinating fires
are so hot and so big sometimes and so
intense
that it creates this huge current of
rising air that current of rising air
can make
winds within the fire zone 60 70 miles
per hour as strong as a hurricane it can
also create
its own cloud or even sometimes its own
thunderstorm
right above it so when an electric
charge builds up in a cloud
an opposing electric charge builds up on
the ground underneath it
and then to get comfortable boom it
releases the charge
discharging a bolt of lightning
obviously drier terrains are more likely
to catch fire than
wetter terrains or places that get a lot
of moisture or
are close to the ocean or swamp land the
drier the fuel
is like a tree or some grass uh the
easier that fuel
is going to burn
wildfires can move at 15 miles an hour
or even faster in localized areas
depending on the wind and
these guys it's heartbreaking 19 of some
of the best firefighters in the world
were killed that day if you get trapped
inside of a wildfire like they
unfortunately were
obviously fire is the main issue but
also fires that big can use up all the
oxygen
in the area so that becomes a different
problem as well wildfires produce so
much smoke and ash into the atmosphere
that it can
travel across states it can travel
across countries continents and oceans
and it can have a
cooling effect because it can block the
sun at a certain location kind of like a
cloud is over you or if it travels at
lower levels the atmosphere can actually
degrade the air quality and be dangerous
to breathe even you know we saw an air
quality effect in texas
from the california wildfires about less
than a year ago
because the smoke you know moves
throughout the atmosphere everything is
connected
that's why what happens here doesn't
stay there uh in the world of weather
next up twister you've got to get
further ahead of it i know what i'm
doing
cut across the field bill i know i have
to get ahead of it so this was made in
the 90s i mean this
got a whole generation of people into
the weather including me and the special
effects even from back in the 90s i
think really hold up pretty well today
this looks like a very realistic tornado
you've got debris spinning around on the
ground which is dirt or whatever else is
chewed up by the tornado
and then the the condensation funnel is
basically that
tornado itself it's the cloud that
extends to the ground that you see here
so the whole premise of the movie is
also pretty realistic you've got storm
chasers who do this
sometimes for a living and you've got
people trying to put meteorological
instruments
in the way of a tornado so we can
actually make measurements inside of a
tornado people
still have limited success doing because
tornadoes are so unpredictable
and so quick it's really really hard to
put an instrument in the way of a
tornado
and then get yourself out of there
before it eats you up too weather
forecasting technology has really
advanced since the 90s but
predicting tornadoes especially exactly
when and where they're gonna form
is still super tricky so if we learn
more about how it works
we can understand it better and we can
predict them better if we can predict
them better then we can keep more people
safe
southeast let's see what she does
[Music]
tornadoes can bend like that i know it
looks kind of wild but especially
what we call a rope tornado which is
this one right here
it's very skinny like a rope from the
cloud to the ground they can kind of
meander and
wave to and fro even as tornadoes
generally move from southwest to
northeast
because that's the way the winds in the
atmosphere are generally blowing when
it's conducive for a tornado they can
still wobble on that path which is
another reason it's
really really dangerous to chase a
tornado and to be that close to it
i'm not sure what the what they
accomplished by going into a dirt goalie
10 feet beside the road where they
already were i guess they're trying to
get in front of the tornado to put
dorothy the weather instruments in the
way but now they're trapped here
also you heard right there the tornadoes
growling
tornadoes obviously don't make any
animalistic noises like that
they've been described as freight trains
pretty often because of the
massive amount of wind and debris that
it's chewing up as we say
but it's not going to sound quite like a
lion or a tiger like this
you really never know the path that a
tornado is exactly gonna take and that's
why storm chasing is still super
dangerous
even with all the technology we have and
people who have been doing it
professionally for
decades they still die sometimes because
they get too close
or in the wrong path of the wrong
tornado and that happened you know just
less than 10 years ago in oklahoma so
tornado chasing is still something
that's really really dangerous even to
this day
tornadoes typically move maybe 20 to 40
miles per hour
so you could technically outdrive a
tornado but we really advise people not
to do that because
at home or at your business or at your
school is the safest place
if you are trying to out drive it a
there might be a traffic jam because
other people are trying to do that and
then you get stuck in traffic and you
get in the path of a tornado or b
the tornado might be moving at 60 70
miles per hour and you're on
neighborhood streets or somewhere else
where you're not able to go that fast
there are a few
easy things to keep in mind indoors in
the lowest floor
of the building or ideally underground
in a basement if you have one and
away from exterior walls and windows
and the reason for being as low as
possible is because if you're on the
second or third floor
the winds in a tornado are actually
stronger up there because they don't get
slowed down by friction with the earth's
surface
you notice they're both looking into the
tornado which is also a theme
of this movie from so close the winds
would be so strong
actually blowing toward the tornado that
you probably wouldn't be able to have
your eyes open much at all because
there's dust and debris floating around
your eyes would really hurt
if you did open them really really
dangerous thing to do
they're actually doing it pretty right
you're supposed to get as low to the
ground as possible
in a ditch or goalie to try to you know
simulate that underground thing to get
out of the wind the common thing about
going under an overpass and wedging your
body under an overpass
has actually been debunked and that's a
very very dangerous thing to do the
winds can funnel underneath there and
get even stronger
and also if multiple people try to do
that then you've got a traffic jam and
you've got people competing for the same
space
that's very realistic tornadoes have
winds so strong they can pull
wooden planks off of whatever they're
nailed to uh even more impressive than
that it can not only throw nails
really really fast it can actually throw
a plastic straw
into a stump of a tree there's a picture
after an ef5 tornado the strongest on
the scale
so really really powerful stuff it's
really tough to guess
based on looking at a tornado how strong
it is as a general rule the skinnier it
is the weaker it is
and the wider it is the stronger it is
but you can't always tell
even if the radar tells you how strong
the winds are which it does
you can't tell how strong it really is
on the ground and if the tornado's just
over an open field
we actually don't know how strong it was
because we only know
how strong a tornado was by based on the
damage it does
to whatever type of building it was and
how stable that construction was
it might be an unknown intensity and
that's the way it goes down in the
record books is an ef
u for unknown where's my truck
tornadoes can certainly loft cars and
farm machinery like you saw
there but it wouldn't happen as neatly
as you saw just kind of
rising up like the resurrection and it
also would be so windy where
our heroes are that they would probably
get sucked up too
if you can lift a car 10 feet from you
then that delineation between
tornadic winds and calm air is not that
sharp
it's it's kind of a blurred line if you
will of really really windy stuff so it
can certainly pick up a truck and drop
it somewhere else it could even drop it
farther away than this
tornadoes can also disappear at the drop
of a hat like that
they're super sensitive to their
environment so if something stops or if
something
goes amiss in the environment the
tornado can just disappear like that
next up the wolf of wall street you
might run into some chop
chop we can handle chop right i mean
it's 170 foot yacht
this movie is crazy so this is actually
everything in this one
as far as i can tell is quite realistic
this is based on a true story not only
after
the actual wolf of wall street in the
90s but this exact situation
and the captain actually had some
reservations because there was according
to the
weather forecast supposed to be a small
storm and some chop as they called it
and then they got into some trouble
chop is just rough waters on the ocean
so
uh if you're in a 170 foot yacht you can
handle some chop chop is like
one to three foot seas or maybe five
foot seas how big the waves are
but uh what they get into is not chop
it's
you know deadly terrifying seas that
no no private yacht like this could
survive storms at sea
we don't obviously have weather
instruments we don't have weather
stations positioned around the ocean
so at sea we rely more on satellite data
so the satellites are orbiting the earth
so it can see all the clouds it can even
detect the winds at the surface and it
does so actually
by detecting the wave height on the
surface and using complex math
to derive how strong the winds are to
get waves that height
so this type of storm is actually called
a mistral and it happens in the
mediterranean sea
and what happens is something causes the
wind from the
alps to rush down through the alps and
across the mediterranean toward africa
and these winds can get really really
strong and they're actually quite hard
to predict even to this day
mistrals are more of a localized effect
they happen
when hot air rises to the south of the
mediterranean sea
so air rushes in to fill the void and
you get really strong winds blowing
across the mediterranean sea
so it's a totally different phenomenon
it's not swirling like a hurricane is
and it's it's a smaller scale feature
than a hurricane is too away
from 20 feet of buildings
you could have 20 foot waves from
hurricane force winds for sure and the
waves in an event like this as strong as
it was can be
50 feet or even higher you probably
wouldn't have the moon at all so it
wouldn't be this bright
at all you'd be in the middle of a storm
and clouds and it'd be quite dark
outside you wouldn't be able to see the
ocean as well as we can see it here
now yachts like this do have really
powerful
headlights basically and also side
lights and backlights so they can light
up the immediate area around them
but we wouldn't be able to see the whole
ocean like this that's kind of for
effect i think
it's every uh captain's worst nightmare
if you have
20 or even 50 foot seas like we had here
and there's a rogue wave rogue waves can
actually be
one and a half times that height or even
twice that height a rogue wave is where
two waves come together just right to
where they kind of
double each other you know it's we call
it constructive interference instead of
destructive interference in physics they
can actually build upon each other
and that can double the wave height
which is uh it looks like what happens
here
next up war of the worlds
this is one of my favorite things about
weather is you know in our age of
digital distractions and phones always
in front of our faces
weather has the power to make everybody
stop what they're doing
i can kind of captivate everybody and
take center stage that's
one of the things that i love most about
it so the light in the middle of it is
baffling i would think there's probably
an alien invasion happening
but a dark lowering of the clouds that's
swirling like this
that could be a wall cloud which is the
beginning signs of a tornado
what the wind is blowing toward the
storm
that is weird there are a few things in
this movie that are actually pretty
meteorologically in tune and that was
one of them he said it's so weird the
wind is blowing toward the storm
so typically in a storm if you have rain
coming out of a cloud
and coming toward the ground that rain
cools the air hits the ground
and it has nowhere to go but out but
this can actually be another sign of a
tornado
because instead of rain cooled air
hitting the ground and spreading out
from the storm
it's inflow it's the storm itself
sucking air
in at the ground level into what could
become that that rotating column of air
that's the tornado
so a typical thunderstorm cloud is just
kind of low and it's
dark and it might be kind of messy we
call it a scud cloud sometimes it looks
like
just debris of weird clouds littered
around
are you okay
we all know what thunder sounds like and
if you're that close to lightning
it's really a loud cracking and like a
deafening
boom so that's what they would be
hearing it sounds a little bit weird
and he's kind of picking up that maybe
this isn't weather-related
you can certainly have lightning without
rain but you can't have lightning
without thunder there's always thunder
it's just you're too far away from it
lightning causes thunder because it
super heats the air to 50 000 degrees
fahrenheit it's way hotter than the
surface of the sun
even so when it super heats the air in
an instant like that
it creates a sonic boom that radiates
outward from the lightning strike itself
and that's thunder if you're super close
to it it sounds like a really loud
crack and if you're really far away from
it it's more of a slow
rolling boom in a lightning storm
if you're outside you are in danger of
being struck even if you're
10 or 20 miles away from the storm and
it's not even raining where you are we
call that a bolt from the blue
because there can actually be sun
shining but if there's a storm next to
you nearby
you can actually get struck by lightning
and killed in a lightning storm the
safest place to be is in a vehicle
which is kind of conducts the
electricity around you and is grounded
or insulated by the rubber tires or at
home
is even better if the worst does happen
and lightning strikes close to your home
or if it strikes your home
it's unlikely to actually conduct the
electricity to your body
it's not gonna hit there again okay
because lightning doesn't strike twice
in the same way
common weather myth lightning doesn't
strike twice it does absolutely all the
time
now the odds of any point on earth
getting struck twice are slim because
you know lightning is the size of a
pencil and you know what are the odds of
that versus somewhere else
but think of the empire state building
or some other skyscraper that has a
lightning rod on it
lightning strikes there all the time so
lightning can strike twice
next up mad max fury road
so what they're driving into is a big
dust storm which meteorologically is
called a haboob the ward has origins in
the middle east where they actually see
dust storms like this but you can get
them here in the desert southwest in the
u.s
this can happen along a front you know a
big gust of wind
that comes from a cold front or from a
thunderstorm with
cool air expanding outward from it
basically a big gust of wind
blows over the desert and it picks up
all the sand and dirt and dust particles
and it locks them into the air even a
couple thousand feet into the air and it
creates this big
cloud that's blowing towards you what
you're really just seeing is a
big gust of wind blowing towards you but
it's visible all of a sudden
because there's all kinds of dust and
particles in it
i don't know that there's uh much of a
difference practically between a dust
storm and a sandstorm
maybe the size of the particles that are
being lofted
both dust and sandstorms create really
low visibility
uh gusty winds and uh
actually hazardous conditions
if a dust storm is ever coming at you
like that going inside is the best case
scenario
if you are trapped outside in a vehicle
you want to stop because you won't be
able to see much all of a sudden when it
hits if you're really outside walking in
it
you want to get eye protection on as
soon as you can you also want to maybe
wrap a cloth around your face or have a
face mask on of some sort
that'll protect your lungs from
breathing in those particles dust storms
can have winds of maybe 30 or 40 miles
per hour maybe 50 miles an hour and a
really strong one
but they're not really known for
damaging winds or strong winds
they're just known for dropping
visibility and looking really
spectacular if you see one
so this is based on reality but it's
dramatized a bit the lightning
there's no reason there would be
lightning inside of a dust storm
so that's one thing that's a little bit
inaccurate
so now it's almost like he's breached
the wall of the dust storm and now he's
inside of it and he can all of a sudden
see everything that's not quite the way
these dust storms or haboobs work
it would just be a constant cloud of low
visibility and dust
you don't really get inside of it and
are all of a sudden able to see you
would not have
sand tornadoes or dust tornadoes inside
of a dust storm there's no reason
meteorologically that you would ever
have a tornado inside of this
a big wall of dust a big haboob can can
blow across you know tens of miles or
even hundreds of miles in a
massive one but typically they last for
a pretty short amount of time maybe
an hour or two at the most the biggest
ones you can actually see them from
space from satellites
if they're really wide and they last for
a little while but the smaller scale
ones may just be a few miles across
and last a shorter amount of time
[Applause]
this is uh one of the more unrealistic
dust storms i've seen in hollywood
movies
when they were driving outside of it
toward it it did look realistic with a
big
you know high and massive wall of dust
but you know once you get inside of it
the lightning is fake the
good visibility that wouldn't happen uh
and once you get inside of it these
massive tornadoes
that would not happen either probably
one of the more accurate things here is
that there can be this reddish or orange
hue to the dust itself it just matters
about what color the land is or what
color the dust is
that that strong wind is picking up it
looks like it's illuminated by the sun
here which wouldn't be the case
just because of the low visibility
caused by the dust cloud
itself next up the impossible
this is quite realistic this is actually
modeled after the 2004
indonesian tsunami one of the deadliest
in history a tsunami is
an undersea earthquake so in an
earthquake
two pieces of land along a fault line in
between them
are either displaced sideways or
vertically
and in this event part of the ground
underneath the ocean
was displaced vertically all of a sudden
more than a hundred feet
so it's like if you took half of your
bathtub split it into two and it's full
of water
and then you lifted half of your bathtub
up really high
that water would slosh everywhere all of
a sudden right that's exactly what
happened in this tsunami and a tsunami
wave
is not like a typical wave that you can
kind of dive through and then come out
the other side
which goes like this a tsunami wave is
just an increase in the level of the
ocean
that just comes in like a wall and it
stays
deep and high so it's not a wave that
crashes over you and then it's gone
it's just like the ocean is all of a
sudden 20 feet higher
and it bulldozes everything that it
takes over
so before a tsunami happens oftentimes
they say that the animals know or the
birds may be flying away
but what you're seeing here is actually
it looks like the wind was blowing out
toward
the sea the ocean can often retreat
in advance of a big tsunami wave and
that actually has a
deadly effect all the tourists here in
indonesia or wherever the tsunami may be
flock out to the ocean and they even
walk in the seabed because
this is so cool you know the ocean is
disappearing what's going on but the
ocean is only drawing out
to come back in in a major destructive
deadly way
and that's what we're seeing here
predicting a tsunami is as hard as
predicting an earthquake there's
actually this
uh tsunami warning center for the whole
world that operates out in the pacific
and all they do is monitor earthquakes
that happen
on the ocean bed or anything close to
the ocean bed that could potentially
cause a tsunami so if there's an
earthquake detected
that they think could cause a tsunami
they'll issue a tsunami warning for the
affected coasts
and in this case folks did not have much
warning at all
tsunamis happen most often in the
pacific basin as opposed to the atlantic
ocean
although they can happen anywhere and
the reason is we've all heard of the
ring of fire
which is the big fault line that circles
around the whole pacific ocean
that's kind of where most of the earth's
active volcanoes are and that's where
the active fault lines are
so that's where a lot of the underwater
earthquakes are a tsunami is just a huge
wave so where you are it might not last
for that long
but it can propagate across the whole
ocean for hours and hours
and it's actually interesting if you
have a really deep ocean this
tremendous amount of energy and a
tsunami wave is actually just a few
inches high
because it's kind of dispersed
throughout the depth of the ocean from
the floor up to the
the air we breathe if you're out on a
cruise ship a tsunami might pass by you
at several hundred miles per hour in the
deep ocean without you even noticing
it's a tiny little wave and then it's
gone
but as it approaches land it slows down
and it builds up higher and higher
because the sea gets shallower
so the tsunami when it hits shore and
shallower ocean bed
they can be 20 feet high 40 feet high or
even over a hundred
feet high in the worst tsunamis so you
know a big wave
crashing into a hotel like this is
absolutely realistic and flowing water
is exponentially more powerful than
flowing air
like wind so you know having a chunk of
water
flowing through a house at five miles
per hour or 30 miles per hour or
whatever
it can wipe everything off of the map as
opposed to you know a 30 mile per hour
wind
which we can all sustain to prepare for
a tsunami you just have to go to higher
land
and hope that you have enough time to
get there if you're vacationing on the
beach like these unfortunate folks were
and there is no warning you probably
will not survive a tsunami they're one
of the least survivable
natural disasters because of the power
of the water
and the drowning risk tsunamis can
certainly travel a few miles
inland from the beach actually which is
pretty terrifying if you think about it
it seems safe that far away
but as long as the land is flat and if
the tsunami has the power to do so
it will bulldoze everything for several
miles
so a big powerful tsunami one of the
most powerful tsunamis we've ever seen
hitting a very flat land like we are
here in indonesia
it's really a worst case scenario next
up dante's peak
great movie i think it's a lot of fun
and it also holds up pretty well today
even though it's a little older
special effects are cool the volcano
science seems pretty realistic to me
what we're seeing right here is the
volcano kind of blowing its top so
all the hot magma and gases that are
built up inside of the earth typically
uh they for one reason or another are
exploding out of the top of this
mountain
so that right there is the pyroclastic
cloud
it's a cloud of super hot gases
from inside of the earth and also ash
and lava
and pieces of rock and all kinds of
stuff it can rise actually at
400 miles per hour and even expand
outward at several hundred miles per
hour
if the volcano is hot enough and
powerful enough it can actually rise so
high into the sky
and for so long it can actually create a
huge thunderstorm cloud
with particles bumping into one another
really fast create electricity
and actually create lightning like most
natural disasters
geologists and volcanologists try to
predict
when a terrible volcano is going to
happen and that's actually the premise
of this movie we're still trying to do
that now there are some markers
in the field of geology that can tell
you that a volcano might be coming but
we still can't predict with any accuracy
when or how bad a volcanic eruption is
going to be
you know a big violent eruption with
that kind of force
could certainly shatter buildings or 18
wheelers or windows
that are in the way and he's telling the
kids to get down there's not much you
can do of course if you're in the path
of this
pyroclastic cloud or the pyroclastic
flow of
magma and hot gas and ash but he's
probably telling them to get down
to stay away from the windows of the
vehicle because there's flying debris
and that might help them a little bit
so that can actually expand outward that
fast and kind of come at you at
several hundred miles per hour the hot
gases and ash
they're rushing at them right now we're
trying to get out of the way let's see
what happens
i don't think they'd be able to out
drive this this hot cloud of gases and
ash coming at them when they're racing
through the town here it looks like they
might be going like 40 or 50 miles an
hour and
you know the force of a volcano can
certainly expand outward
faster than that so they might be in
trouble here driving into a tunnel or a
mine shaft like that might provide you
some protection
from the debris and from what's going on
outside but you know
the direction of the volcanic eruption
is still going
into that tunnel the same way they drove
as well so i i'm not sure they'd be able
to survive that even in there
next up crawl
it looks like we're in the middle of a
hurricane here in this movie some parts
are realistic some parts are not a
hurricane
is a low pressure system a big organized
100 mile across storm or larger that
forms over the ocean
and if the conditions are just right and
the water in the ocean is warm enough
the storm will keep swirling it'll keep
big thunderstorms building
and it gets winds of 74 miles per hour
or greater and then it becomes a
hurricane
this is actually pretty realistic except
it would be a little bit windier than
this
i know from experiencing a hurricane is
almost impossible to stand up in
they don't look too flustered by the
wind which they would be but you also
get what's called the storm surge
flooding where if you live near the
ocean
the level of the ocean actually rises
and that happens for two reasons the
the wind from a hurricane piles the
whole ocean
into the land second of all the lower
pressure
in the atmosphere inside of a hurricane
actually exerts less of a downward force
on the top of the ocean
so if you're not pushing the top of the
ocean down as much believe it or not
this bubble of higher ocean levels
actually forms
in the middle of a hurricane it's from
all the rising air the atmosphere is
almost
lifting off of the earth itself so the
ocean itself is able to kind of
lift up as well and fill that void i
wouldn't suggest walking through this
you see the car starting to float away
even just a foot
of moving water can wash a car away only
six inches of
flowing water can wash me or you off of
our feet even with our best efforts
the other dangerous thing about this you
don't want to be outside in a hurricane
for obvious reasons flying debris
but also because of power lines water is
a really good conductor of electricity
so if that wire is still alive it'll
electrocute you
if you're within even a somewhat close
radius you don't even have to be right
next to it
it's a little bright for a hurricane in
a hurricane the visibility is really low
you can't see the clouds everything's
just gray
and swirling and blowing you don't have
visibility of the cloud bases
or of any bright spots from the sun like
you see here to prepare for a hurricane
if you live near the coast because
remember they only form
over the ocean it's good to have a few
days supply of food
water and a backup generator if you can
to run some basic parts of your home
like maybe the air conditioner
or lights things that you need to
survive of course if a really powerful
hurricane is coming
officials will issue a voluntary
evacuation where you can leave if you
want
or a mandatory evacuation if it's really
dangerous where you have to leave
and it's actually a crime to stay
above us yes this is being in the
hurricane eye
i've only been in a hurricane eye at
night if you're in the eye of a
hurricane in the day that's kind of a
storm chaser or meteorologist's dream
because you get this spectacular
visibility it is completely calm
there's no wind or just a light breeze
and the clouds around you might be
45 000 feet tall and you can actually
see
all of them around you very hard to get
into the eye of a hurricane of course
most
people don't want to be there so not
good for them the eye
wall of a hurricane is actually the most
dangerous part which is
if you think of the eye like a donut
with the cut out in the middle
the eye itself the hole in the middle of
the donut is completely still and it
might be sunny
and no wind at all but the donut itself
surrounding that circular eye that's the
eye wall and that's the ring of terror
that's you know where the strongest
winds are the most lightning
can be that's where all the destruction
takes place so that's another
unrealistic thing if they walked outside
just before the eye got to them
that means they walked outside in the
eye wall which would have much much
stronger winds and be much less
survivable than what we see here
next up everest
this is quite realistic so far you can
get a thunderstorm in the mountains with
lightning and rain
like what is base camp of everest in
this movie and then at higher elevations
you wouldn't experience that as rain it
would be cold enough for snow or
little pellets of ice to be hitting you
of course it'd be super windy in this
storm at such a high elevation and you'd
need to brace yourself against
the wind and brace any exposed skin from
all that stuff flying at you in the air
and this is what's less realistic if
you're climbing mount everest or in any
high alpine environment you don't want
any of your skin exposed
in an environment like this the
windchill is constantly well below zero
it could be 80 below zero which will
give your exposed skin frostbite in just
minutes
and also your eyes you would never
uncover your eyes whether it was sunny
up there
or stormy up there if it's stormy and
windy
there's snow flying in your eyes the
cold wind is really harsh on your eyes
so you need to protect them from that
even if it's sunny and a little less
windy it's so bright up there because
you're above like a half of the earth's
atmosphere you're above it
so there's little to protect you from
how bright the sun is
also you've got a huge mirror under you
and all around you that's snow
so you can actually go snow blind they
call it if you're not wearing really
good sunglasses or really good goggles
so in meteorology the term ice storm
actually refers to freezing rain which
is not quite as exciting
as this it's where you have really cold
air down at the ground which is below
freezing
but then up higher in the sky it's quite
warm so if something falls from a cloud
it falls
as a raindrop and then it hits the
ground and then maybe the surface of
your car
or the road or the bridge is below
freezing so it turns into ice
once it's on that surface an ice storm
doesn't necessarily mean that ice is
falling from the cloud
typically that's just little pieces of
snow that are falling from a cloud
what we're looking at here is like a
warm weather convective thunderstorm
these big it looks like a piece of
cauliflower right but a huge piece of
cauliflower
the updrafts are really strong so that
the cloud is growing and mushrooming and
blossoming
it has really sharp edges on the cloud
we call that a cumulaform
cloud this only happens in warm moist
tropical environments so this is a
thunderstorm you might see in miami
or even in the midwest that could
produce a tornado but this is not the
type of a thunderstorm that you would
see
close to mount everest in the himalayas
you can get lightning
in a mountain thunderstorm even that
high but it won't be as common
and most storms that you'll get on mount
everest they don't look anything like
this they're not pretty
and have sharp edges that you can see
coming they're kind of just like a blob
of gray
coming at you
if you're climbing a mountain like this
just the willingness to turn around
is how i would suggest preparing for
mount everest type of storms
people have gotten in trouble when
they're stubborn and there's a storm
coming and they're
100 yards from the summit but you know
100 yards at 29 000 feet elevation takes
you a while
because you got to walk really really
slowly the willingness to turn around is
a
good survival tactic i think on everest
lightning and thunder are much more rare
with snowstorms that's why when you get
what's called thunder snow
it's a really exciting thing for
meteorologists typically lightning and
thunder are more of a
warm weather thunderstorm occurrence
so there has been lightning on mount
everest before it's more likely down at
base camp than it is
on the summit but you know on a storm
like this they're showing frequent
lightning and
what looks like a summer day
thunderstorm it just wouldn't
quite be like that thank you guys so
much for watching these clips with me i
had a blast this has been my lifelong
passion so this is really what gets me
excited and
hope you enjoyed it as well we'll see
you next time